i got this beautiful gift basket for
sunshine
with this little bear from selena gomez
it's so cute selena gomez sent a gift
basket to cardi b and cardi is loving it
oh yes honey after cardi and her hubby
offset welcomed their son in september
the only murders in the building star
sent the wap wrapper a basket full of
goodies for the baby and even a few
snacks for cardi i love everything about
motherhood it's a lot but i love
everything and cardi loved it so much
she shared her excitement on her insta
story got this beautiful gift basket for
sunshine
with this little bear from selena gomez
it's so cute and it's got treats for me
for when i'm like you know i'm rocking
the baby to sleep at night you know i
get hungry in the night
this is so cute thank you selena gomez
you're so adorable
of course cardi and selena have been
friends since collaborating on takitaki
back in 2018
[Music]
and cardi well she told et a few reasons
why she's such a big selena fan she's
such a sweet person like how can you not
love her it's like oh my gosh you're so
nice you're so sweet and then it's like
when you like talk to her it's like
she's so relatable
and then she's like i love her like it's
just like i love it
and when e.t played selena a video
message from cardi she couldn't help but
gush right back thank you so much you're
so amazing you're so beautiful
such a pretty girl such a cool kid
literally could not stop gushing about
you
i'm obsessed with her she's so sweet and
she's very honest and i respect that
yeah what does that friendship mean to
you it's great because i i felt like
when we got to work on the video we were
able to be there for a while and there
was no pressure everything was super
laid back i just think she's hilarious
and she brings a fiery energy into
anything and speaking of that fiery
energy cardi's chart-topping smash [ __ ]
comes to mind
and while we can't tell you exactly what
it stands for
selena will which is exactly what she
did while speaking with e.t alongside
her only murders in the building
co-stars steve martin and martin short
you know she tells steve lyrics to wwe
wait selena did you explain [ __ ] to them
i certainly why can't you say w.a.p
because that's not what they say that's
not what the kids that's like calling
the usa usa
[Laughter]
thank you for this service selena for
explaining and did you what did you guys
think when you learned the meaning of
wap well i you know i i i've known it
for years that was
[Laughter]
but back to cardi the 28 year old rapper
who also shares a three-year-old
daughter culture with her man is keeping
it real after fans were praising her
body after baby number two people been
giving me amazing compliments on my body
everybody just like carter you so
snatched what did you do you did light
bulb you had a tummy tuck you cannot do
surgery
after you give birth anyways yes i look
snack especially when i take these
paparazzi pictures and i'm like this i
really like this guys i you know i like
to be real with you guys take your
[ __ ] time it's red it's really hard
dealing with kids especially when you do
two kids after you give birth
cardi and offset welcomed their second
child on september 4th and announced his
arrival on instagram writing in part
quote we are so overjoyed to finally
meet our son he has already loved so
much
[Music]